gasps stops identity and the questions
he is dealing with are very much based
and imposters careful beautiful
explanation of the time in which he was
sniffing which is this lead up to World
War one a first world war now your ebook
I mean my profiles I mean we are still
in the wake of the Second World War but
for you it's 9/11 the financial crisis
the Arab Spring as the dominating events
in your life so far so my first question
is what kind what kind of effect had
these events this big offense on your
identity your view of the world you live
in and and who you are it is a can you
what what what did 9/11 to you question
I'm 16 I'm giving away my age like hands
cast off sometimes there are moments in
life which make you think about things
very deeply and 9/11 was a very painful
one I think for many people in my
generation and it posed a whole series
of questions that I had never asked
myself and which I didn't feel that I
needed to ask myself who are you
where do you stand on so many things
that before that I had just been a
British kid and a British school you
know like all my fellow pupils and then
being thrust into the very sort of jewel
that we heard this morning but on a
daily basis of this supposed casual
civilizations where you have these
monolithic blocks and you have to
position yourself between supposedly you
know between a vision of Islam that was
being portrayed by these people the
extremists and the media which I did not
recognize at all for my upbringing from
the way I lived my faith and Western
civilization in which I felt very
comfortable but where I also felt that
there were that space was being
restricted for having a multi-layered
pluralistic identity and so in such
situations you have to either be
subjected to these big structures and
allow them to define you or you need to
take some agency and you need to ask
those questions yourself and explore
them with others and so I found that it
made me in a way it's strangely more of
an active citizen in a way pushed me to
go out and dialogue with others and and
to speak with others who are different
and to ask myself difficult questions as
well and to construct my own version of
of identity of humanism and faith and to
refuse to give in to this idea that you
have to choose one or the other
Jessie you you were in New York at a
time right how do you remember oh yeah I
was 14 so it was my third day of high
school which is a scary time to be in a
new place with new people a new building
and everything so but yeah with the
school in downtown Manhattan so we heard
the plane go over the I was on the top
floor actually of my school building the
first class of the day so we heard the
plane go over and we heard everything
and saw everything and it was I had
already gone through you know personal
tragedy in my life but I had never gone
through it I didn't ever heard community
or national tragedy so that was my first
experience with that and the first
initial thing that sticks out in my
memory is just the way that it created
immediately so much community amongst
the New Yorkers and amongst my teachers
and neighbors and all the students and
there was just such an immediate
outpouring of love and support and
togetherness in the instant of it in the
day in the following days that was so
hopeful and optimistic and really so
beautiful that I mean it's terrible that
it takes tragedies like that to bring
people together but
it was a really powerful thing to
witness at a young age and but what
followed immediately after that was a
real shift in that after that kind of
fell away and the that sort of love and
support started to dissipate then what
rose up was so much fear and you know
fighting and disagreeing and debating
and a lot of you know all the security
stuff and we couldn't get home without a
piece of mail with our address and our
ID and people couldn't come to each
other's houses and but also like you
were saying about the questions because
suddenly we were only 14 we were just
kids in school but now we were debating
and fighting and arguing about something
that was actually real I was very nice
when I was a teenager and 9/11
economical Krissy was a kind of wake up
for me because I will I grew up with the
promise everything will be better every
day better and better better for you
because your parents my parents and
everyone I think in Western Europe after
the Second World War and thanks to
economic bonds deliver and the only
faith was the progress was the
capitalism
my grandfather was so poor without shoes
and my father
like so many father and mother in Europe
were the first not only to have the
opportunity to buy shoes meant to pay
the studies for their children and I was
one of the children and you're the first
generation I'd opportunity to go to
university and not like today choose
whatever you want or do you like ants in
Greek do you like music do you like of
course you can do it is the system
believe in it and then one day someone
said we were wrong sorry so you now you
need to change yourself
change your mind said no don't believe
anymore but that was at the time
progress was a fate it's like talking
about religion the someone don't believe
anymore in your God
you